so today we're going to cancel
um panhandlers beggars vagrants and i
don't mean
the people who stand on the median strip
with a sign or come
up to you in the parking lot at walmart
or sit on the sidewalk with a jar that's
the old-fashioned panhandling
say what you want about it but at least
they're asking for money face to face in
person
also almost all of them are drug addicts
or severely mentally ill or both these
are desperate broken people
i don't often give them money because
frankly i don't really want to
fund someone else's crack addiction um
or my own i don't know i said someone
else's crack addiction like i have one
but anyway
uh but but i'm i'm not mad about being
asked
so that's not what we're talking about a
far worse category of beggar
is the internet beggar and i'm i'm also
not talking here about the person in
legitimately desperate straits trying to
raise money to pay for their child's
medical treatments or something like
that
i'm obviously not talking about people
who raise money for other people for
charitable causes especially if they're
raising money for
say needy abuelas i'm talking about the
rising tide of people
who beg the internet for money for
frivolous reasons or for no stated
reason at all people who start gofundmes
for themselves despite not being in any
dire need
in fact when i did that abuela
fundraiser out of the kindness on my
heart i got messages from dozens and
dozens of people
sending me their own gofundmes and
asking sometimes demanding
that i share their gofundmes and raise
money for them
often their causes were things like
please pay my student loans or
please give me money so i can go on
vacation that was a real one someone
actually asked me to do that
or or help me sir i need money to get my
car detailed
i made the last one up but it's not far
from the kinds of campaigns i've seen
and um we should also say that that even
some of the fundraising campaigns
stemming from actual tragedy or
affliction are at a minimum
some of them sort of weird and
inappropriate and off-putting
because these days when someone suffers
a misfortune especially if that
misfortune generates some attention
online
the first thing they often do is start a
gofundme even if it isn't really clear
how
money is going to help them in their
situation or why they're asking for it
the pitch seems to be something bad
happened to me
and now please everyone give me money to
make yourselves feel better about it
now this is all pretty objectionable but
at least it's better than
another form of cyber panhandling in
which a person simply puts their cash
app or venmo handle
in their bio on social media and asks
people to send the money
for no reason often these days the
panhandler doesn't bother with a sob
story or any story
they just preemptively ask the whole
internet for money and hope for the best
and even that is better than the latest
innovation something i've noticed more
and more recently
and i saw it again yesterday in a
shopping center parking lot
perhaps you've seen this yourself people
who put their cash app or venmo handles
on the rear windshield of their cars
soliciting donations from anyone in the
world who happens to park near them
or end up behind them in traffic the car
i saw yesterday had the person's cash
app information
along with a brief message indicating
that she's a single mother
and any little bit helps me didn't say
she's homeless i didn't say anything
just said single mother any little bit
helps
apparently just the simple fact of being
a single mother regardless of your
actual financial situation
is supposed to be enough to justify
public solicitation
i'm a single mother give me money why
why should i i'm a father of four why
don't you give me money
now i wasn't sure if this windshield
trend was something that i was just
noticing myself maybe these people are
following me around
to torment me specifically i don't know
uh but it turns out that's not the case
i looked it up and found a recent
article from the washington post on this
very subject indicating that it is
indeed a national trend
it says quote when corey roy was heading
out on the final leg of a road trip to
celebrate her wife's
29th birthday in april she decided to
add a message to the rear window of her
hyundai
help us get to new orleans she wrote
adding her venmo and cash up accounts
roy an austin-based hip-hop artist who
goes by mama duke
said in a interview that she was
inspired by fellow road trippers on
tick-tock even 20 would be better than
nothing roy figured
but there was reason for optimism over
the past few months social media users
especially tic toc
have been sharing their own experience
of venmo powered road trips as travel
has revved up again
users have sought and received
contributions from strangers for
graduations birthdays bachelorette
parties anniversaries
even divorces some of the videos have
been viewed millions of times
now the article gives several examples
including one car spotted by a
journalist
who posted it to twitter which said um
just divorced
buy me a drank d-r-a-a-a-a-n-g
then a hetero venmo well at least the
divorce is no mystery here
i mean shameless and greedy is not a
recipe for success in any human
relationship at least of all
marriage one other example from the
article a woman named alyssa harris had
the bright idea to start panhandling
for her bachelorette party it says quote
during a stop early on she wrote a
message on the back of the car as she
had seen a fellow tick tock user do
it said quote last fling before the ring
buy the bride a drink
a friend shot a video and they posted it
to tic toc during the drive it blew up
so fast that harris a dental hygienist
she had her phone propped up on a stand
in the car for directions but venno
venmo
notifications kept flashing i was like
oh my gosh guys
every time i checked there was another
hundred dollars while she thought a few
hundred dollars might come in
i've seen what tick-tock can do she said
she was floored when the total topped
thirty-two hundred dollars yes well who
could think of a more
worthy charitable cause than sending
money to a random
dental hygienist so that she can have a
fun bachelorette party
people in her line of work have salaries
up to a hundred thousand dollars a year
a good number of the people who sent her
money probably make
less than she does but she accepted it
without shame
and that's the common theme here a total
lack of shame
so what is the problem granted if people
are stupid enough
to give their money to some flagrant
money grubber who put their personal
financial information
on the windshield of their car or posted
to their twitter bio
or to tick-tock that's their own fault
right
true but even so there's reason to be
concerned that people in our culture
have become so comfortable
begging the world for money even when
they don't really need it and are hardly
pretending to need it
to understand the problem consider this
consider this
how many of these moochers would
actually go up to a stranger
face to face and say hey will you give
me some money
why why why do you need it oh i no
reason i i just want some i guess
i'm gonna go party later and i you know
i just i didn't want to spend my own
money
on the party so maybe i could spend
yours
how many would do that almost none of
these people would
and yet that's what they do online or on
their windshields or on their tick tock
accounts
now this of course is a far-reaching
problem on the internet people saying
things
they would never say in person acting in
ways they would never act in front of a
physical audience
and whatever you find yourself doing or
saying anything behind the shield of
your screen or keyboard that you would
never even think about doing or saying
to another human in the flesh
you should really stop yourself and ask
why in the case of the panhandlers
they wouldn't do it in person because
it's shameful and embarrassing and
pathetic
to solicit money from strangers when
you're not in desperate need
and are not giving them anything in
exchange
doing it online is not any less shameful
or embarrassing or pathetic but it does
insulate you from those emotions
and that's maybe that's that's one of
the primary dangers of the internet
is it insulates you from from the
emotional consequence
of the things that you're doing in zang
now um you know soliciting money from
strangers
even when you do need it and are
actually desperate can still be quite a
humbling experience
if again you're making these pleas in
person
it should be humbling there's nothing
wrong with asking for help if you need
it but
it's something that should be approached
with humility you're going up to a
stranger and asking that they give to
you while you offer nothing in return
there is a time and place for that sort
of plea
but the fact that you're asking them to
make 100 of the sacrifice for your sake
when they don't even know you should
again bring forth within yourself a deep
sense of humility
it's that deep sense of humility that's
lost among so many of the cyber
panhandlers
there is no sense of humility they feel
no mortification and receiving money in
exchange for nothing
as long as the money comes from faceless
nameless people who do not have to
salute who they don't have to solicit
personally nor
thank personally or thank at all
entitlement shamelessness laziness
these all are the hallmarks of modern
american culture
and so it is no surprise that we have
produced a legion of comfortable
well-fed
well-dressed internet hobos using their
900
iphones to clink their jars to the world
pleading that we might spare some change
though they have plenty of spare change
themselves
i will not give these people a dime but
i will tell them
you're cancer listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated